Nintendo's switch launched earlier this
year has been a resounding success so
you can be sure that they're going to
build on that momentum going into e3 but
to stay up to date on all the latest
Nintendo news be sure to subscribe to
the channel Nintendo has already
confirmed a few exciting appearances
Super Mario Odyssey is set to release at
the end of this year so of course it's
going to have a huge presence odyssey's
free roaming exploration harkens back to
classics like Super Mario 64 and Super
Mario Sunshine and we've already gotten
a glimpse at a few exciting new settings
like the New York inspired new dog city
with splatoon two's July launch fast
approaching we're also sure to learn
more about the story and multiplayer
modes for Nintendo's unique ink blasting
shooter and other confirmed 2017 games
from Nintendo that were likely to see
more of include the action-focused
Fire Emblem warriors the globe-spanning
RPG Xenoblade Chronicles 2 and more than
a few DS titles including the quirky me
topia and the return of captain olimar
inhe Pikmin but going beyond the games
that Nintendo has explicitly confirmed
here's what we really hope happens at
the show
Nintendo have had a fantastic year so
far and I think they really need to keep
that momentum going after the release of
the switch by just giving us more games
so I think this year at e3 hopefully
they will just know that the console is
popular that people love it that they're
going to tell us when exactly we'll be
getting our hands on more games for it
but I want to hear things about Pikmin I
want to hear about third-party
franchises I want to hear about Monster
Hunter coming to the west I love my
switch but there isn't an awful lot for
it right now
antennas already off to a great start
with a Nintendo switch people who have
them love them people who don't most of
them want one I'm part of that is
because of Zelda breadth of the wild
they did an amazing job sort of taking a
classic series and bringing it into the
modern era so if they can do that with
their other series like Metroid for
example I think that's all they have to
do and maybe they should probably stay
away from a lot of their Nintendo
policies that people often don't really
understand what do you some more games
in it pretty simple to be honest there's
a pretty big segment of Nintendo players
who skip the Wii U which means the last
time they played a Nintendo game
on 3ds so to win those players over I
would want to see Nintendo really
embrace the handheld favorite it's like
Pokemon and Animal Crossing for a
platformer that's both console and
handheld in ways those games will be
even better on switch to be portable
they'd be prettier it would make a lot
of sense and you'd have a little bit of
something else to do with those Animal
Crossing amiibo cards to win a three
2017 all Nintendo needs to do is
announce Pokemon stars that's all they
need to do Pokemon stars that they
couldn't they could not release another
game for three years afterwards but if
they're Knights Pokemon stars coming out
before the end of the year I mean I've
already bought switch buy buy another
one maybe probably probably not I'm not
rich
well then sendou needs to port more of
their Wii U games onto the switch
I mean first great is the Wii U's
library was in terms of exclusives like
you know as you know blade Chronicles X
Super Mario maker and even Super Smash
Brothers unfortunately a lot of people
didn't get the chance to play any of
those games if a Nintendo is able to
bring those games over not only will
they be able to introduce a new audience
to some of these great recent games that
they have made but they'll also be able
to buy themselves more time as they've
developed more new games to round out
their library Plus who doesn't want to
play Wind Waker HD or captain toad on
the switch
Nintendo make it happen I want it check
out our GameSpot now app stay up to date
with all the biggest news coming out of
III 2017 GameSpot now is the fastest way
to get the 10 biggest stories of the day
download it on iOS and Android now